with dad in the driving seat it was a
proper family occasion as they arrived
at Thomas's in Battersea Princess
Charlotte seemed a bit uncertain on her
first day doing her best to hide behind
Kate's skirt but Big Brother Prince
George was on hand for moral support
with mum and dad also wanting to be
there to drop her off George has been
going to Thomas's for two years where
the school ethos is to be kind and
Prince William was feeling optimistic
Charlotte was going to like it there -
small talk over it was time to get away
from the low-key press pack which seemed
to be a distraction and get into class
it can be more different from when
William and Harry went to school and
half of Fleet Street turned out royal
author Claudius Joseph says the Duke and
Duchess of Cambridge want to take more
control but are happy to share certain
big days William and Kate think a lot
about how much the media are allowed to
see their children but I think this is a
very important occasion we saw George
going to school for the first time and
inevitably we're going to see charlatan
and then Louie they want them to grow up
in there in a normal family environment
away from the cameras as much as
possible so it's got to be a balancing
act I think as we saw on a rare public
family outing on the Isle of Wight
Charlotte seems to be growing up to be a
confident little girl but her first day
still seemed to be a daunting prospect
for her and probably for mum and dad who
want their children to have as normal a
childhood as possible Rhiannon Mills Sky
News